dylan what's up man yo-yo
there he is
pay me in bitcoin i see you
all right before we get started with uh
with charts graphs and uh and cool
visuals how are you feeling in terms of
bitcoin obviously just from a sentiment
check uh was at 69 000 nice and drew all
the way down uh was sitting around 50
000 uh or kind of high 40s at the
beginning of the year and over the last
two weeks or so has kind of continued to
fall uh down even more is this all
healthy like how do you feel about the
twitter sentiment just talk me through
that yeah i think it was a pretty cool
graphic the other day when it was
comparing january 11th or january 10th
2021 verse 2022 and there's a fear and
greed index and last year was at 90 at
40k and and just like yesterday or two
days ago it was at 10
um and the fear of greed index just
sentiment but uh you know it's crazy
what a year can do i think you know
forty percent correction from all-time
highs
it's nothing but a thing in bitcoin uh
and i think just a lot of the stuff with
derivative market liquidations and then
kind of a lot of the macro talk i think
that's all already kind of been priced
in um if you just look at like say the
euro dollar futures for 2022 at the end
of the year so that means basically like
the market's expectation for the fed
funds rate the pricing at about four
rate hikes so you're seeing a lot of
that uh i think bitcoin just being
honestly the most free market in the
world that's already kind of been
getting priced into the bitcoin market
um and so in terms of you know further
downside we'll have to wait and see but
i think you know 40k is a pretty strong
level for bulls and i think there'll be
a lot of support there uh for the time
being
i think that uh that's a pretty good way
to uh to look at it and uh bitcoin is
definitely the freest market in the
world uh hopefully it'll will uh we'll
stay there um all right so i think that
we've got a number of different uh
graphics and stuff but before we get to
that uh you basically have these like
five key points of understanding um and
i just wanna uh kind of highlight those
first before we get to the graphics so
people keep these in the back of their
head as as we go um the first is
denominating performance in usd or
bitcoin the second is the having effect
on minor revenue the third is interplay
of hash rate difficulty and minor
revenue the fourth is hash price and the
fifth is balance sheets on a bitcoin
standard uh one of the things that uh i
think is important here is you're
talking about balance sheets with
bitcoin talking about denominating
performance in usd or bitcoin uh
historically people obviously have
thought about everything in dollars uh
and one of the reasons for that is they
have to report in dollars and public
companies uh all of the accounting
systems are built in dollars all the
taxes are paid in dollars etc uh before
we get into the actual um uh kind of
charts do you think that that stuff has
to change before people start thinking
in terms of bitcoin or can we have
people thinking in terms of bitcoin
without let's say being able to pay
taxes or change your accounting systems
or anything like that yeah i mean
you know using bitcoin as a unit of
account uh on an individual basis is
definitely a little bit easier than a
corporate uh kind of entity um just with
the accounting standards and you know
the the tax reporting and all that but i
think more of it's just kind of a mental
model um you know operating on a bitcoin
standard um things get frequently a lot
cheaper and a lot more expensive uh you
know just a lot bigger kind of moves
than you would on say a us dollar
standard where things just gradually get
more expensive over time um with bitcoin
there's obviously volatility right where
say things on the bitcoin standard got
you know 40 more expensive uh over the
last couple months but that's after you
know anybody that's been doing been
operating on a bitcoin standard for the
last couple years uh life's gotten a lot
cheaper you know to the extent of 90 95
um experiencing these kind of
exponential gains and purchasing power
and so i think more so it's just kind of
a mental model but more and more people
and entities and
institutions around the world and you
know i think slowly nation states are
kind of coming to
operate on this bitcoin standard mental
model framework
it's gonna be amazing all right let's
get into charts we're gonna go rapid
fire through these over the next 20
minutes bitcoin mining difficulty nice
little pink line here what's this
showing us
yeah so uh this whole kind of slide deck
is just i've heard a lot of buzz about
publicly traded bitcoin miners and so i
think you know what we really want to do
here is is if you're buying publicly
traded minor stocks or evaluating them
how are you actually evaluating the
performance so right here we have mining
difficulty and this is in log scale so
if you look at a linear scale it's
basically uh it doesn't look like
it looked like it was at zero until like
2020 and then all of a sudden just
went parabolic upwards but in in log
scale
mining difficulty is appreciated by
you know i think like 10 orders of
magnitude or something outrageous uh you
know as bitcoin mining went from just
doing it on cpus where you could mine 50
bitcoin uh just on your old crappy
laptop to now you know these just an
unbelievable amount of hashing power all
over the world so understanding mining
difficulty and how basically bitcoin
supply inelasticity works where every
commodity in the world as it gets more
expensive than sent to produce it
obviously increases
but with bitcoin there's a difficulty
adjustment so
as it gets more lucrative to produce to
mine
it becomes incrementally that much
harder uh to get the thing and so it's
unlike any asset in the world in that
sense and i think it's really important
to understand that uh if you're going
into the business of bitcoin mining or
buying these miners
all right next we've got hash rate here
uh which also seems to just be going up
along with obviously the difficulty but
uh is there any end in sight for uh for
hash rate
yeah so i mean essentially this is the
same chart uh difficulty is basically
um there's there's a 10 there's a 10
minute block target over at that 200 i'm
sorry 2016 uh block interval right so uh
every 2016 blocks uh if blocks are
coming in faster than that 10 minute
interval then difficulty will adjust
upwards and and likewise if it's slower
than that 10-minute target then it'll
adjust downward so this is showing the
same chart but hash rate is derived by
basically how fast blocks are coming in
relative to how difficult it is to mine
blocks
all right mining difficulty and hash
rate when you look at this this is just
literally overlaying them on top of each
other for the most part yeah this is
just uh this is in linear terms and this
is just the last uh two years just for
some uh
you know just for a visual graphic okay
then we've got hash price which is the
minor revenue per terra hash what is
this showing us
yeah so this is uh that same chart over
time and this is in u.s dollars so as
bitcoins appreciated um you know a bunch
similar to how hash rate has risen
but you kind of see basically and this
is in log scale but over time a marginal
unit of of hash rate gets you less and
less in terms of dollars as as hash rate
continues to just go exponential and so
what you kind of see is that you know a
lot of these inefficient rigs over time
uh have to get plugged into more and
more efficient uh uses of that energy to
stay competitive and so it's kind of
this darwinistic process where uh you
know basically the revenue is is
trending to zero in bitcoin terms and
that's what we're going to show in the
next one but this one is in in usd terms
it's just pretty crazy how much uh hash
rate continues to to increase over time
all right then we've got hash price the
minor revenue per terra hash in this uh
this next chart
yep and so this is uh this is just an up
close uh view of the same thing and this
is in linear terms and so this is uh
dollar denominated but basically what
you can see is uh and if you look
closely to say may of 2020 you see
basically a vertical line down uh that
is the having event and so uh if you
tend to look at a lot of publicly traded
miners uh
basically in bitcoin terms what you'll
see is that they trade at a multiple uh
or pretty closely to this to this metric
here um because uh hash price is is
taking that minor revenue it's dividing
it by by the hash rate so as hash rate
increases uh it is basically the profit
margins for a lot of these miners
compress
got it then we've got uh more of the
having's kind of zoomed out here you can
see three halvings on this next graphic
and basically that's really what's
helping to drive this down over time
yeah so this is that same hash price
metric but it's it's denominating in btc
terms um so when i say i say things on
twitter a lot like uh basically it's
it's the production price of bitcoin the
cost to produce a marginal satoshi is
going is trending towards infinity and
basically what this means is hash rates
essentially there's an economic
incentive crash rate to increase forever
um if you factor in moore's law
basically you know processing power
computing powers is increasing
exponential terms uh as well as you know
just there's this huge economic
incentive to monetize wasted energy
resources all over the world uh what you
see here is that along with the havings
and the difficulty adjustments if you
look very very closely you'll see kind
of it's like a step function all the way
down in this chart and that's every time
difficulty increases or there's a having
event where you can really see it
it becomes that much more difficult to
mine a unit of bitcoin or satoshi uh and
so uh this is really key to
evaluating publicly traded miners or uh
you know bitcoin bitcoin mining in
general and and we're kind of working
our way in to see some of these charts
in bitcoin terms okay and then if we go
ahead and we go to the next chart here
this is i think just a having zoomed in
where you can see a very significant
drop uh in a in a single one um
when you look at this uh what exactly is
uh is this showing uh in terms of uh on
on this graphic here
yeah so i've kind of put a lot of
similar charts in this slide deck but
really what i'm trying to show is uh
with a mix of linear and logarithmic
scale just just you know how how fast uh
this ecosystem is moving so this chart
is in linear terms and what it's showing
is basically how much bitcoin a marginal
unit of hashrate or a terra hash can get
you um so if you know if you plug in
asic what can you expect for revenue and
what you can basically see is since
since 2017 since the top it's become uh
unbelievably more difficult to mine
bitcoin uh you know per unit of hash
rate and so and you can see that kind of
that having there there was a decrease
of 50
and so uh when you look at a lot of
these publicly traded mining charts and
btc terms uh i think you'll notice you
know you'll notice something pretty
staggering and it might look a lot like
this chart
got it and then this last one here uh
around the uh the hash rate uh this is
the zoomed in on the having drop
uh that's pretty significant when you
zoom in on it is that something that we
should expect every single time there's
having
yeah so this is minor revenue uh per
terahash and btc terms and so uh what
you can see here is a lot of the
variants and and the kind of those those
step functions are that's difficulty and
hash rate and you can see um some of the
things like the minor capitulation and
with difficulty have this huge downwards
adjustment that's that spike you see
kind of in in july where it actually
became a lot more profitable for any
miners that were able to remain plugged
in
but yeah this is this is in btc terms uh
and every having you can expect going
forward eventually uh fees will will
make up a dominant majority of of the
minor revenue but for now um you know
fees as a percent of minor revenue is
still one to two percent and that block
subsidy uh currently at six point two
five every every ten minutes or every
block uh makes up a uh dominant share of
the minor revenue
all right now uh these next charts are
uh are gonna be fun uh we've got riot
denominated in btc riot being the
publicly traded uh mining organization
we have mara hutt
bitf and hive basically you've got five
of them here what are you one trying to
show and then we can kind of click
through each one of them as uh as we go
but uh they're all down against bitcoin
um and so what exactly are you trying to
uh to show here
yeah i'm not not trying to discourage
anybody from buying mining uh mining
stocks i have no affiliation with any of
these companies i don't really have an
agenda all just you know the the sharks
that i was showing earlier we're really
trying to do one thing that's trying to
get people to think in a bitcoin
standard um and so you know a lot of
these if you look at a lot of these
companies especially over the last uh
last two years or since say the bear
market in 2018 in usd terms they're
they're up a huge amount um but
especially since before the 2017 bull
run or say you know at the bottom of
2020 if you're looking at a lot of these
companies in btc terms
they're down almost you know some of
them 90 90 plus
and this is because if you're evaluating
these companies
and their valuations in in bitcoin terms
the fact is the fact of the matter is
that basically their their revenue um
and if they increase their hash rate
they can attempt to keep pace but the
revenue in bitcoin terms is essentially
programmed to go down forever
basically all minings are in bitcoin
terms and so um you know playing with
publicly traded miners investing in them
allocating in them
is totally fine and you know i encourage
people to do their own research but
at the end of the day is you know a lot
of this performance is is somewhat
expected if you kind of understand the
economics of bitcoin mining um and so
the companies that kind of hyper
bitcoinize their balance sheets the best
uh will will keep up you know say
michael saylor and microstrategy since
since adopting a bitcoin standard i
think are slightly underperforming
bitcoin itself uh and that and their
balance sheet is essentially 100 bitcoin
now uh but a lot of these companies
you know they're they're buying a bunch
of asics are trying to plug them in uh
and since they're say ipo or just you
know i chose three four year time frames
for a lot of these companies um they're
underperforming bitcoin by a wide margin
because in in usd terms the revenue is
increasing and they're growing and
they're growing fast but in btc terms
the revenue is decreasing
programmatically so because of the
having and the difficulty adjustments um
so these are just some things to kind of
consider when you're evaluating uh say
investing in mining companies or or even
you know any company really uh it's just
you know the fact of the matter is it's
going to get uh it's programmed to
become you know uh to produce a marginal
unit of bitcoin it's going to get harder
forever if hash rate continues increase
so uh you know just some just some ideas
got it and so when you think about
denomination in bitcoin obviously uh
denominating stocks in bitcoin uh like
this are uh are pretty eye opening uh if
you were to do this for the s p 500 if
you were to do this for uh nasdaq etc
let's say in 2021 all of them are down
against bitcoin
and that's just a function of bitcoin
was up you know 65 they weren't and so
naturally uh that denomination ends up
looking like it's just down uh do you
think that professional investors kind
of um not the the retail crowd not the
uh bitcoin crowd but wall street firms
or hedge funds uh big banks like
eventually do they start to change the
way that they actually denominate uh
these investments as well or do you
think they're so kind of codified into
the the fiat mentality and the
denomination in dollars that they stay
uh without looking at it this way
yeah i think it's pretty standard for
like say a lot of fund managers to get
you know benchmark to the s p or to the
nasdaq or just you know to it to a
standard basket of equities and i think
it's going to be increasingly common for
a lot of these managers as bitcoin
becomes you know it's already kind of
entrenched itself as a macro asset but i
think you know over the 2022 over the
next you know say four years or decade
really what you're going to see is
bitcoin itself becomes a benchmark
and i don't expect the volatility to
completely go away i actually expect
volatility to persist for for the most
part
but i think the reality is as this asset
class grows in relevance and kind of
acceptance uh it's going to be kind of a
benchmark to say you know why would i
give you any money or why would i invest
in your company when i can just buy this
thing and outperform you know almost
everything and so whether that's for you
know publicly traded miners or whether
that's for
hedge funds and their performance um you
know if if a simple retail investor can
go go buy bitcoin and outperform you uh
and a lot of times with bitcoin you know
not in 2021 with so much volatility but
through most of bitcoin's history it was
the best uh in inval adjusted her
in risk adjusted terms it was the best
performing asset as well and so uh it'll
be interesting to see how it all plays
out but i think bitcoin increasingly
becomes a benchmark
for performance for all of wall street
and uh investors in general
yeah and when you think about this one
of the things that's most interesting to
me is uh if somebody was to go and do a
bunch of research on publicly traded
companies and spend a bunch of time
trying to understand valuation metrics
and uh cash flow uh you know investment
strategy return on investment uh taxes
like there's so much that goes into
evaluating let's say one publicly traded
business let's just say amazon we were
talking earlier about bill miller and
his conviction in amazon and kind of how
he breaks that business down uh and then
if you try to take that
analysis and bring it to a bunch of
different public companies there's this
feeling of like you never can actually
accomplish all of the analysis you can't
analyze every single public company you
can't actually uh continue to find
what's the company that's you know got a
brand new angel around okay what's this
what's this what's this what's this and
so there's this sense of like
just dollar cost averaging into bitcoin
and like bitcoin and chill
it brings almost this like mental
clarity it brings this like very simple
long-term belief of like look i don't
need to be a genius i just simply need
to understand a market structure and
then i just chill and like i'm going to
be perfectly fine is that kind of how
you think about the difference between
like the super hardcore analysis that
goes on at these hedge funds these large
uh financial firms versus like the
everyday bitcoin pleb that just says i'm
just gonna dollar cost average into this
and uh you know good luck let's see what
happens here yeah i think i think you
kind of nailed it there there's a lot of
there's a growing uh you know amount of
people out there that say you know none
of this makes sense the cost of capital
is manipulated and broken
and i think there's a real reason that
value investing since say 2008 or 2010
um you know has underperformed by a wide
margin is value investing is basically
baking into the cake of this assumption
that the cost of capital or that the you
know the interest rate is is fair is
actually is positive really
so when real yields are negative and
you're trying to what's the fair value
of a company or a discount cash flow
analysis when when you're plugging in
this this formula into the equation
you're plugging in this this
assumption this variable and it's the
cost of capital and it's you know what
is real yields right now five negative
five negative six percent um and so i
think that's where value investing uh
has gone you know gone wrong this last
decade and i think that's where it
returns on a bitcoin standard eventually
obviously there's a lot of volatility uh
denominating everything in bitcoin using
bitcoin as your unit of account uh in
2022 2021 2020. those who did have done
done great but i think you know right
now a lot of people are saying i'm not
even investing i'm just saving money uh
and five years down the line ten years
down the line uh when when these
companies uh you know maybe are on
bitcoin standards themselves or bitcoins
appreciated by another order of
magnitude or two uh it'll make sense to
start investing and get that you know
positive roi in btc terms uh but for now
you know while investing is very
expensive i'm just gonna save some money
joe john what do you guys got dylan
what's going on man good to see you
again
uh so my question is just how interest
rate fits into this narrative right so
the general idea is obvious that uh
interest rates will rise and risk on
assets will depreciate in value or have
a pullback specifically tech stocks and
stuff like that but i don't know if
we've necessarily seen a period of a
sustained period of high interest rates
when it comes to bitcoin's cycle right
or life span so i'm curious to know how
you think or how you think about
interest rates in the grand scheme of
things like where does this take bitcoin
over the next 12 24 36 months
yeah it's a great question i think
that's the that's the trillion dollar
question i think a lot of the people
even you know running the show with the
fed don't even know and they're just
kind of winging it and they'll put on a
brave face and go out there and pretend
like they they know how it's going to
all play out but they're just winging it
i think for the most part real real
yields can't sustainably rise uh real
yields can't even probably break zero
like we can't have a positive real yield
without the entire system just
collapsing
and basically since you know 1981 when
the interest rates you know cyclically
topped uh we've seen just a secular
trend of lower real yields over this
over this time and that i think that's
kind of uh that's needed to keep this
whole thing glued together and so you
know with bitcoin uh you know we we have
a couple you know key assumptions or
things that we uh you know would like to
say we understand which is uh like kind
of what we covered earlier that it's
going to become harder to produce
bitcoin uh basically
not forever which which you know kind of
sounds outrageous but as long as there's
an economic incentive to mine bitcoin
people will do it uh and as long as
that's true and people can plug in asics
all around the world with just satellite
signal and some energy resources uh it's
going to become harder and harder to
produce the thing uh there's a you know
unforgeable costliness to bitcoin an
asset similar to say gold um so
regardless of if there's you know credit
expansion or deflation a deflationary
bus bitcoin will have that uh production
cost and it'll have that absolute
scarcity that no other asset on the
planet has so
you know whether if interest rates rise
sustainably i think everything gets hit
i think there's a you know really good
buying opportunity for bitcoin uh
similar to say march of 2020 where
bitcoin bottomed first
and there was a lot of volatility along
the way in a 50 drawdown intraday
but it bottomed first and then obviously
went you know parabolic in the later
part of the year and so uh because of
the response of the money printing and
so i think interest rates can't
sustainably rise without something
breaking uh and i think when the thing
breaks the next time whatever it is
probably something in the bond market or
euro dollar market or you know anything
in this kind of uh
very fragile financial system uh but the
response from that and what comes and
what happens with bitcoin after that i
think i think that's the real next big
move here
gotcha john what you got dylan what are
you seeing with long-term holders for
short-term holders obviously we have
seen a drastic decrease in price are
long-term holders still accumulating
right now and is it the short-term
holders that are selling
yeah so short-term holders are you know
a little bit underwater here just
because um you know we were ranging in
that 50-60 k range for a while we saw
long-term holders actually
basically contrary to what we've seen in
the past distribute into the drawdown
and i think a part of that had to do
with the macro worries and fears that
have kind of popped up over the last
couple months um you know we've seen
like say arc invest or a lot of these
what people would call speculative risk
on assets have sold off in a big way and
i think just more so kind of the the
macro wall street investors that have
come into the space who treat bitcoin
like a you know risk on asset and aren't
evaluating things on a bitcoin standard
uh you know they they probably trim
their bitcoin holdings you know just
looking at correlations and treating it
just like another asset in their in
their portfolio uh in the meantime a lot
of people that have kind of come to
understand this as a monetary asset and
are evaluating things in bitcoin terms
are pumped because you know their income
in bitcoin terms has risen and they're
they're saving a lot more with their
with the dca right so i think there's
like kind of two classes of investors
that are allocating this thing and on
the margin you know the big guys that
are that you know are investing
trillions of dollars across asset
classes can have a pretty big effect on
this price but for now i think uh you
know a lot of that's already been kind
of priced in and the long term holders
are starting to to accumulate again
what are your thoughts on bill miller
saying his portfolio is 50 bitcoin
i mean
that's a chad move i think uh you know
shows shows a lot of conviction and i
think what uh you know is kind of maybe
not lost in all of that is similar to
kind of what paul tudor jones came out
and said in 2020 not not in terms of
allocation size because paul tudor jones
only had five percent but you know this
very very respected uh investor in the
wall street circles billionaire investor
um who a lot of people you know probably
behind the scenes copy trade or or you
know listen very intently to what he has
to say um you know paul tudor jones had
that effect in 2020 where a lot of
people said oh my gosh you know i need
exposure this guy knows what he's
talking about and i think you know bill
miller coming out and saying you know 50
yeah i don't care if it goes down i'm
gonna buy more i'm never gonna sell um
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of billionaires out there that probably
realize that they're short bitcoin and
they need some more
gotcha i think that's a great way to
look at it is if bill miller's in 50 and
paul tudor jones is out two to five it's
a big difference big delta so we're
gonna see what happens here uh before we
let you go very quickly uh any
predictions for 2022 whether it's price
whether it's a milestone what are you
thinking looking forward to in
2022 yeah i think we're going to get a i
think we're going to get a few more
nation states that come that come pretty
hard into adopting bitcoin whether it's
legal tender or maybe adding it to the
reserves or strategically mining bitcoin
uh maybe you know an energy producer
i think that's coming uh and i think uh
you know duke ellis kind of hinted at it
a little bit but uh there's a lot of
people and you know i guess nations that
are kind of looking at the playbook that
el salvador uh has has started to
implement um and you know there's some
bumps along the road obviously but uh i
think i think that'll come and i think
you know we'll see el salvador uh with
this with this bond offering right
they're just kind of routing around the
imf uh laughing that in like b kelly
actually laughing in ims face on twitter
uh and not even paying down the debt
that they owe and saying we're just
gonna raise uh a bitcoin bond and so if
that's over subscribed or that's you
know there's some you know sufficient
demand for that offering
it'll be really interesting to kind of
see the response from other you know
countries in similar situations that uh
you know want to want to get financing
or want to
maybe attract foreign capital
all right my friend
can we get uh
300 000 followers by the end of the year
we're at 104.7
you'll see new profiles let's see what
bitcoin does new profile pick that is
right my mom's happy with that one
[Laughter]
all right uh i appreciate you coming on
newsletter is linked in uh in the
twitter bio too so
let's uh let's go man we got a lot of
work to do in 2022 counting on you pay
me in bitcoin basically
yeah there you go it is perfect do that
again real quick we get a little
screenshot of you then yeah they're
perfect yeah all right
i appreciate you coming on uh for anyone
who isn't following dylan go follow him
if you're not subscribed to the
newsletter go subscribe to the
newsletter and i'll do this again next
tuesday my friend
so guys